our next application of constrained
least squares
is linear quadratic control like
portfolio optimization this is a topic
where there
are multiple entire courses you could
take on nothing but just this one topic
it's also something like portfolio
optimization that's that's widely used
so let's look what what this is the
setting
is we have a linear dynamical system so
we have a state
xt that's our state
here and it's a it's an n vector
we have an input ut and i'm using the
traditional terms that that people would
use and control
um that's an m vector um i have an
output
that's y t here related to the state um
that's a that's the output y t um
a t is called the dynamics matrix
b is called the input matrix c is called
the output matrix as some other sensor
matrix is another name for it
and uh and here we have a linear
dynamical system now very
very often here uh a b and c don't
depend on t
uh in which case it's called a linear
time invariant dynamical system or an
lti system
um and i should also mention that these
usually don't represent
x t u t y t they don't represent the
actual value of
the quantities of interest they're
usually deviations
of those quantities from some standard
values
right so it should be the deviation from
standard so from some standard operating
condition or something like that
um and usually it's set up in such a way
that x equals zero is good that means
that the system is working
like the way it's supposed to this is
just usually um
u equals zero means that the input is
kind of what it would normally be or
something like that so that's the idea
okay so linear quadratic control uh the
basic idea is we are going
to choose a sequence of inputs over some
uh time horizon the time horizon we're
going to take
is over the with the times uh t equals
one
uh going up to capital t so we're going
to go
t capital t steps into the future uh
that's
that's going to be our time horizon and
our our job is to choose
uh a sequence of inputs that's ut
uh for little t equals one two to
capital t
uh actually for the ut we only have to
go up to t minus one uh because
x t only depends on u t minus one
okay um now we're also gonna we're also
gonna go ahead and choose
the state as well the state sequence so
x
that'll be x1 up to x capital t
okay and so what we're going to do is
we're going to have two objectives it's
a by objective problem in fact this can
easily be
you can add more objectives so it's a
more than by objective like a
multi-objective problem
but the simplest objectives would be
two things and these sort of have names
the first one
is this it is the sum
of the of the squares essentially of the
outputs and
and the idea is you want those small in
fact in
many cases uh you actually choose the
output to be literally
the things that you want small and
that's of course equal to this that's
the same as
as this thing because uh c1 x1 is y1
um and so this is a measure uh some
people call that a measure of
you know regulation or something like
that it's it's you want the output
to be small and remember what the output
is yt kind of represents a deviation
from a desired state so that's why you
want it small small means everything's
cool and the input is going to be the
sum
of the norm squareds of the inputs
and remember the inputs only go up to t
minus capital t minus one
because that's the last input that
matters uh to
x sub capital t um okay
so and then this is also godless it's
got another name it's
you know it's like the input energy or
something like that but it doesn't
matter
that's it so these are the two things
and you want both of them small
now so we put that together in a
bi-objective
uh in a bi-objective uh we scalarize
that by that those two objectives
and we write it as j output plus j input
output means that the output is
uh small and input means that you're not
using a big input to
uh to mess with this thing um and then
row is a
is a a parameter it's positive uh
that tells you how much uh input the
input deviation irritates you compared
to output deviation
so that's that's all rho is um
okay now we also have here the dynamics
right so
that's we that just tells you how the
next state is related to the current
state and the current input
and then we have two other constraints
um and these are initial and final state
constraints the first one says that x1
at x at little t equals one
is x in it that's the initial state and
then x capital
t is the is going to be the final state
and that has to that has to be equal to
something which is given which is called
x desired
um x in it is also a given
so that's the idea and there are many
different sort of variations on this
problem
um you know in many cases
x init is the current state of a system
and x desired is zero so it says please
get me from here to zero
uh over capital t steps
that's that's generally called the
regulation problem another one
is basically you're in some state and
uh there's a high level command that
says get to this state at that time
and then this would be non-zero uh x
desired
okay um so here in this in this
optimization problem we got a lot of
variables
um which is it's it's the state
uh at at all of the times and it's the
input
up to well t minus one okay
so this is the so-called linear
quadratic control
problem it's it's to choose the u the
sequence of u's
and the sequence of x's it's a big
problem um actually what we're going to
find out is
it is absolutely nothing more than a
constrained least squares problem
so it's a big one but nevertheless that
is all it is
okay um oh and i should ask i should add
how uh
it's used in control uh row is chosen
um you know i'd like to say there was
some
principled way to choose row there
really isn't uh what happens is
you choose row and you look at the
trajectories and
if you like them if the u is too big
then you crank
uh if u is too big you crank up row
if if if you'd like the output to be
smaller
j output you would crank down uh row
so that's that's just the idea and you
kind of just look at it under simulation
and have an idea of what you like
okay now let's see how this works uh
what we're gonna do is um this is uh
you'll recall that that's
this is y1 and that's up to yt here and
so
uh we're going to minimize um this big
expression here um
this is like this thing here is j1
uh j sorry j output i think we called it
right and this thing here
is rho times j input
like that okay
and then we have the dynamics equations
and then we have the initial and final
state constraints
now this whole thing this big
complicated problem here it looks very
very complicated
can be written as just a constrained
least squares problem period
just that so this is we're going to
write this this big thing up here as
minimize a tilde
z minus b tilde subject to c tilde z
equals d
tilde and i have to tell you what all
those things are so
i'll start by telling what z is z is
all of our variables all stacked
together so it's the
entire state sequence and that's the
entire control or input sequence
and so uh it's got you know capital t n
plus t minus one m variables so it's a
it's a big thing
and if we were to if we wanted to
extract for example the
inputs uh from z we would
just slice into z and take the
appropriate parts and that would give us
our sequence of inputs
okay so that's z i still have to tell
you what are a tilde b tilde
c tilde and d tilde okay
so um let's first look at a tilde and b
tilde
um so a tilde is this uh
giant matrix here um you have to put uh
z
here and z let's remember what z is z is
x the x is stacked on top of the u's now
a tilde is
a block it's what people would call its
block diagonal meaning
diagonal matrix of course is a matrix
with you know non-zero entries only on
the diagonal
but here here it's only these diagonal
blocks
which are non-zero and so if i multiply
this matrix by you know x1 and this goes
down to xt
and then u1 all the way down to ut minus
1.
if i multiply this big matrix by this
vector and i do that block wise what i'm
going to get is that it's the it's going
to look like this it's going to be
c1 x1 and this goes down c
t x t and then i'm going to get
square root rho times
u 1 and then down to square row u
capital t minus 1. now
when you take the norm squared of this
well
how do you take the norm squared of a
block vector it's the sum of the squares
of
the norm squared of the components and
you know what it's
norm norm squared c1 x1 up to you know
and then these are
when i square that i get rho times norm
squared u1
and you know what that recovers exactly
this uh our objective
okay so that's how to write oh and b
tilde is zero so there's no target um
actually we could have b tilde non-zero
that that means that you're
you're trying you want your states or
whatever to track a trajec a given
trajectory
by the way that also comes up in
practice uh but anyway
okay now we're also going to write
the the these sets of
linear equations as one gigantic set of
equations
linear equations on z and let's see how
we do that
well again it's a big block matrix
the first one is a1 minus i then zeros
and b1
and if i multiply that if you multiply
that in your head
by this vector right which is the x1
down to xt u1 down to ut minus one
you'll figure out what happens this
first equation says the following it
says
a1 x1 uh
minus x2 plus
b1 u1 equals zero and that's
that's the same equation as saying x2 is
a1 x1 plus b1
u1 so that's the correct equation the
first one and you can check
that these each of these rows get these
rows give you the dynamics equations
um this bottom one i mean it's very
simple but if you look at it if you
multiply this giant block row
by this thing it basically says x1
equals x init
and if you do it down here you get x
uh capital t that's the final thing is
equal to x desired that's your desired
terminal state so okay so
all of this is just to say that we have
taken a problem that looks pretty
complicated
and frankly it is kind of complicated i
mean you know in classes i mean i
i teach classes on this and it gets kind
of complicated and you know it's your
weeks into a class before you even
before you get to this and what the
solution is but the truth is here we
know exactly we could just we just write
it like that and then it's solved it's
that we know
you'd form a kkt system and you need to
solve it
by the way the kkt system that you would
form here
would be extremely sparse i'm sure it
did not escape your
notice that both a tilde and c tilde are
extremely sparse and so when we would
form
the kkt system here it would be very
very sparse
and actually it would be even more than
sparse it would end up being
uh you know sort of have a very uh
specific structure
um and that means that for example
sparse matrix method could actually
solve it like
super like shockingly quickly okay
um okay so uh so what we've done is
we've reduced
the linear this is the so-called linear
quadratic control problem
and we've reduced it to a very big
constrained least squares problem
that's it and we just solve it so we
know everything about that you just
solve it
and then you're going to get it means
that the data in the problem are
i have to give you the a i's bis ci's i
have to give you row that's a parameter
um i have to give you x in it and x
desired and that's it and capital t
of course and so from that we will
construct the optimal
uh trajectory and input uh sequence for
it
okay so we'll look at an example it's a
very simple one
uh but it gives you a rough idea of kind
of you know what this does
um oh i should say this is actually used
like uh
very very frequently it's used in all
sorts of stuff in in uh you know
for control of cars space vehicles
engines you know all sorts of it's just
used everywhere
well things very closely related to this
okay
so we're gonna look at an example now uh
it's gonna be a baby example just to
give you a rough idea so here's our our
matrix a
i don't know what this thing is i mean
it's some it doesn't matter what it is
maybe it's a mechanical system
actually no it doesn't matter here's b
ah
and here's c again not that any of this
would mean anything to you but
it's a small example uh here's the
initial condition
probably generated randomly just to give
you a rough this just you know and then
the final
uh the final state that we're going to
take you to
is zero um and we're going to do that in
time steps okay so that's that's what
we're doing 100 time steps we're going
to take you to zero
oh that's called by the way that's a
special case when x desired is zero
the problem is called the regulator
problem because we're
well roughly we're regulating the state
to zero to zero being some kind of
desired state
okay so that's going to be our example
it's going to be pretty big oh m
which is the dimension of u the input is
is 1.
so we're going to calculate for
ourselves 99 inputs they're scalars and
we are going to calculate a
uh a state trajectory which is a hundred
long and each state has dimension three
so
again if i did my arithmetic right which
there's no reason to believe i did but
if i did in my head i get 399 variables
honestly that's a tiny that's that's
just a tiny
uh problem right but even so it can be
solved like in
with shocking speed just because of the
special structure
okay all right so here what we've done
is uh here here we just simply vary row
solve the problem and and
and calculate j input and j output and
sure enough you get this beautiful
trade-off curve this is what you know
this is what you'd expect to see as a
trade-off between these two objectives
and you know it says the usual thing it
says uh you can have j output low
but you're going to do that by it's
going to cost you lots of of input
right and you can have j input
low um and it's that's going to cost you
two
uh in terms of j output right so and
we're going to look at two things uh
i'm sorry three points on the trade-off
curve row equals one
row equals point two row equals .05 and
let's think about what these mean
row scales how much
how much we we care
about the input so that's what rho does
and so if we look back here let's think
about it before we even look at the
plots what we think we're going to see
what we're going to see
is as you reduce row what should happen
is the
input size should get bigger i mean
that's what this means that's also shown
directly here
right but also the output size
should get smaller right and so because
that's really what the trade-off is in
some sense
you are spending a large input
um in order to achieve a small
output i mean that's that's kind of what
this is about that's the trade-off
so we'll look at these three things um
and we'll take a look at uh what the
trajectories are
and what we're going to show you is the
input applied the input it's on the same
scale
in these three things right so and sure
enough look at this when row is one
which increases you know as we increase
row
we increase the uh the amount the
amount we care about the input and sure
enough look at that if you compare this
and this and this you see u is roughly
speaking getting smaller
at the same time y is kind of getting
bigger i mean not dramatically so
but the point is if you kind of look in
here you'll see that uh
you know y is you know it's pretty small
oh sorry no no no
sorry that that's not small small is uh
zero here
um yeah so let's see yeah so no it's
right that as
y uh and here it this gets uh it gets
bigger
okay so that that that's how that works
all right
next topic uh it's related and it's
actually a very common way
the linear quadratic regulator is really
used when i said before
that a variant of linear quadratic
regulator is actually widely used in
practice
it's actually this one it's called
linear state feedback control so let me
let me explain that i think we've seen
it before earlier in the class but i'll
say what it is
it's a really simple way to control
um a linear a linear system or it's work
people do it for nonlinear systems as
well it's just this it's called linear
state feedback control simply says takes
the state
and multiplies it by matrix k and
gives you that's that's the the input
here k is a it's a single matrix it's
called
the state feedback gain matrix for
obvious reasons right because it
it takes the it takes the states that's
x t you multiply by k
and what you get are the inputs to apply
um
and this is this is very widely used um
and it's especially used when uh x
the there's a it's vague about x t the
basic idea is that x d should go to zero
or v near zero
um and t is not specified right so um
t would be specified typically in
problems that involve things like
docking or landing or something like
that where there's a specified time when
you want to be where you have to be
where you need to be
um in in most in many other applications
it's it's vaguer it's like no i mean
follow this trajectory or
um you know adjust my airplane so that
i'm flying at
you know i i want to fly at forty
thousand feet level flight mach point
eight two or something like that
and you know that's uh and
they don't say when and you don't say
112 seconds from now you just say no
just you know
move towards that um and so that's
that's the setting
uh in which you would use something like
a a linear state feedback control
which just for the record is exactly how
airplane control systems work
um okay all right so
there's um so there's there is actually
a
a a way to choose k it is the most
widely used
way to choose k um and
uh now the derivation i'm going to show
of it is not the one that you would
normally see what you would normally see
is well it gets kind of complicated
there'd be things
like algebraic riccati equations none of
which you need to know because i'm going
to show you actually a simpler way that
derives just from the constrained least
squares problem that we
just looked at that's this what we'll do
is we'll set x desired equals 0
and then we observe that
the u t is a linear function of x in it
let me explain
why that is let's go back and take a
look at that formula
it's right here um why init
apply sorry x x init
appears in d tilde it is in fact the
here you go it's that entry right there
okay now when i go to a
uh a constrained least squares
problem like this the solution
is actually linear in b tilde and d
tilde and you can check that that's that
comes directly from
the specific formula for the solution
that comes from
uh you know the kkt system okay so
all right so what that tells you over
here
is that in the linear quadratic uh when
we solve the linear
quadratic control problem what happens
is that the first input u1 is a matrix k
times x in it x in it is x1 by the way
we can find k easily uh sin we simply
use x init is equal to e one up to e n
and we solve the problem uh for each of
these um
we just calculate it and that gives you
k um
so roughly speaking what it says is that
uh
it's it's k is the thing that relates
the initial state
to the first action you would take when
your job is to solve that linear
quadratic regulator problem
oh and also by the way uh get the uh get
this
get in the end after capital t
steps get to x desired equals zero okay
so that's the
that's the idea um let's look at an
example of how that
works um so what we're going to do is
the blue curve
shows you what happens if you do this
optimal thing and with it with a fixed
deadline of capital t equals 100. well
you do various things this is the input
you apply you do this you do all sorts
of stuff then you do something crazy at
the end i don't know what it is but then
it's all over at t equals 100 and then
you're zero
here okay um now here's the state in
that case the or the output the output
looks like this it goes like this
it bumps down and then a t equals 100
brings you to 100 that was
actually the requirement and then it's
just flat 0. okay
if you look at what happens when we take
u t
equals kxt with the matrix that is
derived in that very simple way from
that big
from the solution of the constrained
least squares problem
that's this red curve like this and it's
asymptotically going down to zero
and here's the same one here right
and so that's how that works uh this is
uh
actually this is very widely used right
so there are
in fact you know packages that just will
calculate
these state feedback gain matrices uh
for you that's
this is what they do so